Salter Springs Valley is a closed basin
surrounded by mountains an increasing
number of cranes call it home for the
winter the greater Sand Hills come from
the northern prairie pothole States
Idaho the Dakotas Nebraska and oz where
they breed the lesser Sand Hills make an
even longer migration they come from the
North Slope of Alaska and Canada and
about 20,000 of them come across the
Bering Strait from Siberia Tom wood
works for the southeastern Arizona bird
observatory this is a relatively new
phenomenon here in southeastern Arizona
50 or a hundred years ago they were very
few sandhill cranes here and a couple of
things have happened one has been the
growth of Agriculture and agriculture is
really a benefit to the crane in
wintertime water drains from the nearby
mountains and forms these playas or
temporary Lakes which are perfect for
wintering cranes the cranes like the
shallow bodies of water that can get out
in the water and be safe from bobcats
and coyotes
the cranes leave this playa lake early
in the morning fly out to the cornfields
and feed on the waste grain the corn
that was missed by the mechanical
Pickers and then come back here
mid-morning and loaf the rest of the day
so the farmers don't mind the cranes in
fact they like the crane because they're
cleaning up the waste corn after a tough
morning of eating all the corn they can
find the cranes return to the playa to
rest and digest sandhill cranes mate for
life and stay together in family units
it's easy to pick out families of three
or four birds even in the air for many
birds migration is instinctive but
sandhill cranes have to learn to
relocate
the young birds are taught the finer
points of migration by their parents
among the lessons learned by these birds
this is a good place to spend the winter